Thank You mr. president Owen Jensen with
EWTN newest millions of school kids
across the country are all including my
own bored Restless learning a little bit
online but it's better in the classroom
you know that yeah and they're my kids
they want their clothes crawling the
walls and climbing the walls and my wife
is about to lose it right so many of
them are watching right now what would
you say to those kids right now
elementary school middle school high
school what would you tell them right
now who are watching from home I would
say that you are a citizen of the
greatest country anywhere in the world
and we were attacked like nothing that's
happened possibly since 1917 many many
years ago we were attacked and we're
winning the battle and we're going to
win the war and it's not going to take
hopefully that much longer but we have
to win the war and I would say that they
have a duty to sit back watch behave
wash their hands stay in the apartment
with mom and dad they look like they're
lucky to have you as a father and just
learn from it but you know they're there
the young people have been tremendous
they some of them are very happy not to
go to school you understand that perhaps
yours perhaps not but they've been we've
had to no we have literally had no
problem but again they should just sit
back and be very proud of our country
because we're doing it for them you know
ultimately we're doing it for them more
than anything else if you think about it
the other thing that's nice and and the
one thing that has come out and I
learned this again it was reaffirmed by
President Xi last night at my
conversation the young people are really
this is an incredible phenomena but they
are attacked successfully attacked to a
much lesser extent by this pandemic by
this disease this whatever they want to
call you've got a germ you can call it a
flu you can call it a virus you need you
can call it many different names I'm not
sure anybody even knows what it is but
the children do very well it's almost
the younger they are the better they do
I guess the immune system is sadly for
some of us their immune system
is stronger but actually I'm very happy
about that but they have been attacked
for instance the Spanish flu and if you
look at the h1n1 these spine if you take
a look at the the the swine flu which
was as you know not so long ago that
attacked very strongly young children
kids middle aged people everyone ages
ages a factor here so your children
should be in good shape but just tell
them to be very proud of the country
okay